مع مضي اكثر من مئه ساعه وتضاؤل الامل في
وجود ناجين بدات تفاصيل انقاذ جديده تحكي
ما هو اقرب للمعجزات
في هاتين تشلت ربيعه
البالغه من العمر 27 عاما من تحت الانقاض
والركام بعد 120 ساعات وكانما يتحدى واقع
الحال واصرار المنقذين مختلف الهمسات التي
تتحدثه عن تراجع فرص العثور على ناجين
[موسيقى]
وهنا في كهرمان مرعش انقذت الفرق العامله
رجلا ظل محاصرا تحت انقراض الزلزال لمده
140 ساعات يتلو الرجل ايات من القران
الكريم بينما يجري نقله
[تصفيق]
تروي الصور وتفاصيل مذهله اخرى وكانما
التمسك بالامل يهزم مختلف العبارات التي
تفقي بضعف احتمالات العثور على ناجين
ويلهم فرق الانقاذ التي تعمل في ظروف
بالغه التعقيد في المضي قدما بحثا عن اي
حياه تخرج بين الانقراض المميته
[موسيقى]
وعلى الرغم من مرور اكثر من مئه ساعه من
وقوع الزلزال المدمر تواصل فرق الانقاذ
مسابقه الزمن بحثا عن ناجين وحتى عن ضحايا
ما زالت تحاصرهم الالقاب
صحيح ان احتمال العثور على احياء بعد هذه
المده قد يكون استثنائيا لكنه ليس بمستحيل